the ragazzi Marsh is a 20 kilometer long
stretch of wetlands in northern Rwanda
Francis misaka is a leading
conservationists in the region this one
first of all help to filter filter to
filter the water that is a very key to
blame at about the same time the swamp
habas these different buds as you can
see but another aspect is that this one
is if is it feeds to two other legs on
the other side but remember also this
one are the swamp feeds it into in
toluca hydropower station so those are
very key aspects well as to why this
swamp has to be protected the wetlands
are home to many birds including the
gray crested crane and endangered
species and the ebis the areas where the
birds nest raise their young and search
for food or under threat one of the
greatest danger pan now is that people
sneak in sometimes because you cannot
protect everywhere cannot put security
everywhere so sometimes people come in
and cut the grass which is not good for
the swap because it exposes the water to
evaporation but another aspect like I
said is the soil erosion because the
swamp is kind of in this in the valley
and so once it rains during the rainy
season because most of the the hills
around are not well protected with trees
so the soil comes into this one local
families need the grass for their
livestock they're already having trouble
finding fodder since the hills have been
largely deforested without trees the
soil erodes it's a huge problem across
Rwanda in this region the silt in
dangers the marsh and lakes
Francis Misaki meets regularly with
local farmers but there are no simple
solutions people here know that damaging
the environment will also destroy their
livelihoods urology joke wanna be born
yay amazon bateria raha recoger corrigan
20 years ago there were tall trees and
lots of forests here the people cut down
a lot of trees now they're all in need
of firewood you've got the money the
population keeps growing there aren't
many animals here anymore Carlina noni
issue of God I shushan got tougher gun
one approach is reforestation planting
new trees could hold the erosion and be
useful in other ways the hazelnut shrubs
for example can be used in raised bed
gardening the branches serve as fodder
so the car is no longer need grass from
the marsh initially the thought trees
were not good for the gardens the
thought trees would do do are competing
with their crops but with the time with
the with the sensitization and education
they have now learnt that trees can
coexist with the with the goddess and
with their crops the International Union
for the Conservation of Nature maintains
5 nurseries where they grow seedlings
including fast-growing eucalyptus the
work provides jobs and it's already
produced four hundred thousand young
plants some of the trees will be allowed
to grow to stabilize the soil others
will be used for firewood the seedlings
need to be watered twice a day it will
take years for them to grow big and
strong
the nearby tea plantation also needs
watering twice a day normally the plants
don't require irrigation but for the
past six months there's been no rain the
tea factory is the region's largest
employer and it illustrates the dilemma
faced by the people here tea production
uses lots of electricity water and
firewood the tea leaves are dried using
hot steam three hundred and fifty
kilograms of tea consume a cubic meter
of firewood the factory manager has now
installed new more efficient ovens so we
cut down the use of fire by forty seven
percent we working with the forestry and
team there to try and look at a better
yielding varieties of blue gum trees
that will use less land and be able to
provide us with a required I filed the
region needs reforestation to help
maintain the local water cycle
hydroelectric power is playing a growing
role in Rwanda forty percent of the
country's power comes from water so
hydropower is also suffering from the
lack of rainfall
Oh Cobie gara gara today we're cool the
water level is lower than it used to be
the guanaco are celebrating the power
plant has become more difficult google
the marsh is a very vulnerable system
that we badly need the water to generate
electricity con una troca manama Zetas a
mocha
the torrents that slowed from the
wetlands have become weaker all the more
reason to protect the marsh and the
species that are at home in it people
here are determined to do what they can
to save it from destruction it is my
wish that this continues to exist
because it is very important to this
area it regulates the it reduce
resistance the climate around it gives
the water to the hydroelectric power and
we need water for economic development
and all that so in my point of view I
would like to see a beat the legs beat
the water build the the ecosystem around
maintained and for our future
generations